Good afternoon. Before we
start, I've been told that you need to understand that that code up on
the screen is the way you can enter questions if you want to.
If you're here, you can also go to the microphone, but of course, we have a lot of
people attending virtually.
I'm Dr. Margaret Tempero. I'm a medical oncologist at the University of
California, San Francisco, and I hope you're all really enjoying this
fantastic meeting here in San Diego.
It's my honor to serve this year as chair of the selection committee for this
year's AACR Dan D. Von Hoff Award for
Outstanding Contributions to Education and Training in Cancer
Research.
Established by the AACR in 2021,
this award honors individuals who have made significant
contributions to the education and training of cancer
researchers at all career levels, especially
early career investigators.
The award is named for Dr. Daniel D.
Von Hoff, an outstanding researcher and clinician,
who has not only made immense contributions to cancer drug development,
but also instrumental in mentoring and guiding the careers of
countless clinical fellows and junior clinical faculty around the globe,
many of whom hold leadership positions in the pharmaceutical industry and
academia. And I actually count myself as one of those
individuals who has been profoundly influenced by Dr.
Von Hoff's work, and it has really helped shape my career as
well. This year's honoree is a physician, scientist,
and leader whose commitment to mentorship and training has...
Sorry.
The 2026 AACR Dan D. Von Hoff Award is presented to Dr.
Charles W.M. Roberts, Executive Vice President at St.
Jude Children's Research Hospital, Director of the St.
Jude Comprehensive Cancer Center, and a practicing
pediatric oncologist.
Dr. Roberts is an internationally recognized leader in the study of chromatin
remodeling in cancer. His laboratory has made seminal
contributions to understanding how mutations in the
SWI/SNF chromatin remodeling complex drive
malignancy, and how these discoveries can be translated
into therapeutic strategies. Dr.
Roberts is widely regarded as an outstanding mentor,
known for providing rigorous scientific training,
alongside thoughtful, individualized career guidance.
His trainees describe him as someone who teaches not only scientific
rigor and critical thinking, but also confidence,
resilience, and how to navigate career setbacks
with wisdom and perspective.
Many note that even years after leaving his laboratory,
he remains among the very first people they call for candid
advice and steadfast support.
Dr. Roberts has also made important institutional and national contributions to
cancer training.
He serves as principal investigator of the NCI
K12-funded St. Jude Pediatric Oncology Career Development
Program, supporting early career faculty and
patient-oriented research. He also led St.
Jude's partnership with Damon Runyon to establish the Damon
Runyon St. Jude Pediatric Cancer Research Fellowship
Award, and hosts an annual career development retreat for
awardees.
In addition, he contributes to national education and training efforts through
advisory and review roles.
Dr. Roberts has extended his educational impact globally
through his creation and leadership of The Science of Childhood Cancer,
an interactive virtual seminar series launched in
2020. Developed in response to the disruption in
scientific exchange during the COVID-19 pandemic,
this series has become a major international forum for
education and mentorship in pediatric cancer
research.
To date, it has hosted more than 140 lectures and
engaged over 10,000 attendees from more than
120 countries, while highlighting rising stars in
cancer research
and fostering discussion across basic, translational, clinical, and
population science.
His many honors include Dana-Farber's Steven E.
Salen Leadership Award, which recognizes the ability to
guide, inspire, and motivate others.
These qualities, together with his sustained commitment to education and
scientific leadership, have made him a deeply respected
figure in the cancer research community.
It is my great honor to introduce the 2026 recipient of
the AACR Daniel D. Von Hoff Award for Outstanding
Contributions to Education and Training in Cancer Research, Dr.
Charles W.M. Roberts.
Well, thank you, Dr. Debono. I appreciate that very gracious
introduction.
First, disclosures, and then second, and most importantly,
is deep thanks to AACR, to
the committee that picked me, to Dr.
Von Hoff for setting a bar to shoot for in
mentorship.
I think it's common when one gets an award lecture to say that they're
deeply honored.
But in this case,
I really can't think of being more honored for something that is about
career development and helping people for the next generation.
It's something I've been passionate about throughout my career, and so to
get recognized for this really
is an amazing honor for me. So thank you to everyone
who was involved.The next thing after I got the notice
from Marge Foti that I had been selected for this and would be giving a talk
was,
what the heck does one put in a talk on this at
AACR? I've done mentorship talks and I've done science talks.
And so I called some of the former recipients and
talked through it. And what I've decided to do is
interweave science and career development
mentorship together. And so to do this, I've actually put together
visual cues. When you get a red bar across the top, I'm talking science,
and I'm going to use a blue bar because I want to transition back and forth
between these two things as I go along
through a career trajectory, then I want to pull together some science
points and some takeaway points on the mentorship front and education and
training front as well.
You'll get my one red-blue bar here.
A quote from Danny Thomas, who's the founder of St.
Jude Children's Research Hospital,
that I've seen, and I really love this, that, "Success in life has
nothing to do with what you gain or accomplish for yourself.
It's what you do for others."
And I've given this a double red-blue bar because I think this is as true in
science when one is just going along and doing science,
as well as when thinking about career development and education.
Okay, so I'm going to start with ultimately talking about
some themes in cancer oncogenesis, cancer
development, what are the mechanisms, how do we think about therapy,
and pull us forward to 2026.
But I want to start where my career began and as people had impact on
my development. So I was in the lab of Stan Korsmeyer
at Washington University in St. Louis, and I signed on an
MD-PhD program, and we were looking for genes that were activated by chromosomal
translocations in leukemia. At that time, it had been noted
that there were chromosomal translocations into the T-cell receptor,
immunoglobulin receptor loci, and sort of a nascent idea that this
was dysregulating things, but what was downstream was unknown.
And so I jumped into this, and what we found,
my summer rotation was finding on a Northern blot a transcript that was very
highly expressed, and not knowing what it was,
I decided to go back to the second year of med school at that point, but then came
back to the lab to work on this. And so we ultimately found it was
a homeobox-containing gene. At that time, we called it HOX11.
And then I went on for my PhD studies to try and figure out what does HOX11
normally do. And what we found
was that when I knocked it out in mice, the mice had no spleen.
And it was expressed in the spleen, and ultimately what became clear was
this was a transcription factor that was a master
regulator of spleen fate.
And spleen is actually one site that blood develops.
And so the model became, what's happening here is
turning on a transcription factor that normally forces development of
a blood-forming organ, and if you do that in a lymphoid progenitor,
that can be bad in the wrong setting, and that can drive cancer.
And so this concept then began to emerge that
aberrant expression of lineage-specific master transcription
factors can drive cancer. People like Tom Look and others
were working on other transcription factors, translocations, and
finding out something
similar.
But this was the beginning of an inkling in the back of my mind because at that
point in time, cancer was really thought about as chromosomal
instability, abnormal numbers of chromosomes, and DNA damage.
And so, hmm, what's going on? Well, what you're finding is promoting
cancer is ectopic expression of a transcription factor.
Now, in parallel, sort of a light bulb went off for me as I was doing that
work on the
control of HOX11 in the spleen and was getting ready towards writing a paper.
I wrote an abstract for the ASH meeting, and I gave it to Stan
to review,
and it came back completely rewritten.
I sort of like to tell people that the word "the" and the last period stayed, and
everything else in between was completely redone.
And as I read what he wrote, it was so much better than
what I had written as a grad student, really taking into account the
entire field of leukemia transcription and just weaving a
beautiful story. And this was
a
truly valuable lesson for me as I began to think
about the communication, not only the discovery of science, but how does one
communicate around that? We submitted that, and
then with his rewrite, I ended up on the plenary stage at ASH as
a graduate student, now presenting in front of 6,000 people.
And so the takeaway was that a good mentor can turn a
crappy abstract into a plenary talk for a student.
And it stuck with me that if I had been
alone, I would have been on a poster session in some corner
of ASH. The quality of the work was there,
but being able to communicate the ideas and helping people understand what it
meant was phenomenal. And Stan was
wonderful individual.
Always described himself as a pig farmer from Illinois, one of the most humble
folks, despite being an HHMI investigator.
Okay, so I finish up there, and I've learned some things, and I go on to
postdoc training in Stu Orkin's lab.
And Stu, I knew to be a phenomenal
scientist. He was focused on hematopoiesis
at the time. I was really interested in cancer, but I thought, this
is somebody that will provide phenomenal training.
And that was
backed up this weekend when Stu was the recipient of the
Breakthrough Prize,
recognizing the impact of what he's done for sickle cell
disease.But then I was thinking, "Okay, what am I going to do?
It's a hematopoiesis lab, but I'm interested in cancer."
And then at that time, Olivier Delattre's group had just published in "Nature"
that there were inactivating mutations of a subunit of a chromatin remodeling
complex present in a nasty childhood cancer.
And I thought, "Hmm,
what's going on here? And what might be of interest?" And
so these tumors are highly aggressive cancers of early
childhood. They strike babies and toddlers.
They can occur in kidney, brain, and soft tissue.
And ultimately, there is biallelic inactivating
mutations of this gene that's had multiple names over time, now most commonly
called SMARCB1 in the lab or INI1 in the clinic.
And it was known to be this chromatin remodeler that had been discovered in yeast,
but it was really thought of as kind of like Pol II, it's just there to
transcribe. And so a real surprise that this thing would be
mutated in cancer, and why would something that's sort of fundamental
transcription be altered?
And at that time, we only knew of the two families of SWI/SNF that are shown on the
left
that both have SMARCB1 as a subunit that really docks on the
nucleosome.
The third family we and others discovered over time.
But to put this in context,
and this is a beautiful figure made by Hayden Malone.
You'll hear some more of her work coming up.
What we now know about this complex is that it binds to nucleosomes,
utilizes the energy of ATP hydrolysis to slide or
eject nucleosomes. And as I'll show you, we really
began to find that this is what is going on at enhancers
and making room for transcription factors as you see there
working together.
And it turns out that this thing really is a tumor suppressor.
So as I was a post-doc now, decided to make
knockout mice, and as we inactivated,
100% of the mice got cancer, and the median onset was only 11 weeks.
And so that was half the time it takes for cancer to be caused by
p53 deficiency, and it's even faster than p53
deficiency with Rb haploinsufficiency.
And so what was going on here when perturbation of a
chromatin remodeler can do this?
And so really now then began to get from the grad school
studies, aberrant expression of lineage transcription
factors. Transcription factors can drive cancer.
And then from the post-doc, starting to be, well, wait a minute, the
receivers of those transcription factors, the chromatin remodelers
that work with the transcription factor shown here as an activator,
are really, in some ways, a one-two punch to how transcription is
being controlled. And so now the lesson begins to emerge that you can either
perturb the transcription factor or you can perturb its receiver, the
chromatin remodeler, and these can be some of the things that will drive
cancer onset as fast
as ever been reported. The other things in genetically
engineered mouse models, messing with the DNA repair pathways
tend to lead to cancers around 40, 50, 60
weeks. If you overexpress a transcription factor, you
can get it again in the 10 to 15-week range.
And so while we like to think about cancer as disrupted
genomic stability,
really, if you mess with the transcription lineage control,
that's what can really give you cancer quickly.
And so began thinking about then, might it really be that disruption of
transcriptional control is a core mechanism driving cancer?
And what's been going on with that chromosomal instability is rolling the dice
until you get the right players. And so, yes, rolling the
dice more frequently, being exposed to radiation will in fact pick up the
frequency by which the key regulators get hit.
But very frequently, those are now turning out to be the transcription
machinery and chromatin regulatory machinery.
So then I'm finishing up my post-doc and getting ready to launch my own
lab, and there was Nancy Andrews, an investigator
in my division. And she had just been recruited to be
the dean of the medical school at Duke, and she knew I was
starting my lab. And so she said, "Charlie, I'm going to tell you
how I recruit research technicians." And she said, "Here's the
problem. We're in Boston. Cambridge is right across the
river. As soon as you get someone who's good as a research technician,
the
pharma companies double their salary, and you lose them.
And so here's how I've gone at this." She wrote to
regional colleges to recruit graduating seniors to do two
years in the lab before grad school or medical school.
So she handed me the email addresses of the departments of biology and
chemistry at about a dozen liberal arts colleges
in New England.
And what I found was amazing. These individuals were
really stellar folks that were excited about the future,
excited about science, really wanted to work hard, and were
driven and were so fun to work with as they
would come back with new ideas
and thinking about the science, not being a pair of hands at the
bench. And this really then, as I
began to invest in this more and more, career development then
became a two-way win. So as I thought about how do I help
these folks get into their grad school or med school of choice,
and how do we set up these two-year positions such that it really
tees them up for this?
It turns around, and I'll say a little bit more about that
coming up.
Okay. So then I launch my own lab, and I'm thinking
about what is this chromatin remodeler doing?
How does it really actually work? At that point in time, it was just
known to move nucleosomes.
What does it normally do? What are the consequences of the
disease-associated mutations in the SWI/SNF subunits?
AndMight we be able to leverage this information
to think therapeutically and about vulnerabilities from
these mutations?
So while that first paper was in a rare pediatric cancer, and I got
interested in it thinking because mutations in rare pediatric
cancers have often turned out to be a canary in a coal mine--
retinoblastoma, a rare pediatric cancer, but the disease that taught us
about the RB gene and pathway. And so
sure enough,
as others in other labs, not my lab, began looking across
all sorts of different types of cancers and looking for mutations,
it now turns out that at least nine different SWI/SNF subunit
genes are recurrently mutated in cancer, and collectively,
20% of all cancers, adult and pediatric, carry
a mutation in a SWI/SNF encoding gene.
And so SWI/SNF mutations also now vary
and somewhat surprisingly,
maybe not so much surprising now, but the mutations also turn out
to be the basis of neurodevelopmental disorders.
And so a mutation in a SWI/SNF subunit that is germline heterozygous
mutation
leads to
neurodevelopmental disorders, and inactivating mutations
contribute to cancer.
And so this complex has now emerged as a major tumor suppressor,
and it was really exciting because it pretty much was
not on the radar.
In terms of cancer, it was thought about by
transcriptional people, but this was the last thing that would be going on in
cancer, and yet it now turns out to be not quite as frequent as
P53 and some others, but one of the most frequently altered
complexes. So, what's really going on?
And so I decided to leverage that postdoc work and the models we were thinking
about because as we sequenced those tumors,
some work by Elizabeth McKenna, who is now the
executive editor for "Cancer Discovery," so thinking about
people who have gone on from grad school to have impact,
found that these tumors had the lowest rate of
mutations that had ever been seen at the Broad Institute at that point in time.
As we sequenced the exomes,
there was an average of four base pair alterations in the exome,
one of which was always loss of SMARCB1, and the other three all appeared to be
random.
And these were diploid tumors. So we had this incredible
scenario that almost appears to be a cancer
driven by a single gene mutation, inactivating mutation.
So what's going on there, and how can that possibly work and fit
with prevailing paradigms of the day?
It also brought up this real challenge.
We all love the story of CML and Gleevec, and what it basically
says is you get a cancer-altered mutation.
If it's got a nice pocket and it can develop a chemical in there, you
can really transform the outcome.
But what are you going to do here
when you have one gene mutant and it's gone?
How are you going to target that,
right? And if this actually turns out to be a mechanism that's underlying 20% of
all cancers, we really need to think about that.
How do you target that? So while we all love the idea of
targeting oncogenes, we have to think more broadly about what's
going on.
So I want to just-- to go to the first two points,
just a few papers to bring you up to speed to some of the
more recent data I'm going to show.
What we basically found was that by manipulating these and looking at
them, that this complex is essential for enhancer function.
It binds at enhancers, it mobilizes nucleosomes, and it enables transcription
factors to bind and activate lineage-specific
development. It's also at promoters, but as you disrupt
the complex, it really harms enhancers much more than
promoters. And then in the bottom left, we got this additional clue
about two years ago that it turns out that certain subunits of
this complex are actually mitotic bookmarks, meaning that as cells go through
mitosis and the genome is completely restructured,
they bind to DNA to help the cells remember what their fate should
be as they exit and to enable the activation of
genes early in G1 that are important for
the particular cell identity at which place the SWI/SNF
complex gets built where they are bound.
Okay, with that as background,
one of the things that I had thought about and been impressed by was
reading about SWI/SNF, which was originally developed in yeast, the power of yeast
genetics as people did screens to understand what genes were where.
You didn't really have to know function.
You mutagenize the yeast, and you begin to find out what's going on.
Then that moves into Drosophila, and genetic screens in Drosophila
begin to reveal pathways and genes that are working on.
But mammalian systems had been far too complex to do that.
And then one day, I was talking to Bill Hahn and Levi Garraway when I was at
Dana-Farber Cancer Institute, and they told me about an idea they had.
Bill had something called Project Achilles at that point in time.
What if we take a whole bunch of cancer cell lines,
and then we use shRNAs to turn off every gene in the genome
one by one, and we now ask which genes are essential for
particular cancer types? We can begin to now do a
screen, a genetic screen in human cells that will let us
understand. And that was the beginning of the Cancer Dependency Map, and I
jumped in at that point in time thinking that this could be really
powerful. And so the Cancer Dependency Map, and now what we've
launched called PDEP, which is a subset of this but is focused on pediatric
cancer. There's now over 1,000 cell lines, many different
types of cancer, all of which have been sequenced DNA, RNA
methylation. Then you do CRISPR screening.
Initially sh, now it's CRISPR screening.
Turn off every gene one by one.And you can say all the RAS mutant
cancers, what are they dependent on that non-RAS mutant cancers are dependent on,
et cetera? We're also now into chemical drug perturbations.
So this is an active thing, and then you find out the vulnerabilities, and
then the fun begins of beginning to work up a target.
So,
this is a story that we just published a couple of years ago now, led by
Sandy Radko-Juttner. Sandy was somebody who joined the
lab as a research technician. She was interested in a two-year
stay before going on to grad school.
Came in, was really amazing, decided that
as she picked grad school, she was going to pick the brand new St.
Jude Graduate School of Biomedical Sciences, and then decided to come back to
my lab for her PhD training. So I was delighted that
after a couple of years of exposure, she decides to come back.
And then here she's working with Jackie Meyers, who's a phenomenal computational
biologist in the lab. And so we asked the
question then, what dependencies or vulnerabilities result from
inactivation of SMARCB1?
So we loaded in a bunch of rhabdoid tumor cell lines.
Now remember, these are diploid cell lines that just have SMARCB1 loss of function.
At that point in time, there was about 729 other cancer
lines. We put in about 12 to 15. These numbers have gone up, as you'll
see. You do genome-wide CRISPR, you select for 21 days, and you
look for genes that are either depleted or enriched
specifically in the genetic background you're interested in.
And so at this point in time, here's this gene called
DCAF5 that jumps off with a Q value of 10 to the
negative 16th or 17th, something like that.
I guess it's 10 to the negative 22 over here.
And so
find it to be-- actually, there was two separate screens.
This was the newest version of DepMap at that time, and this was the original
screen. So we see it in two different screens, highly significant, and was
not a vulnerability in any other group. So this was really specific.
So what the heck is this thing? I'd never heard of it.
It was mentioned in four publications in PubMed.
It's called DDB1 CUL4-associated factor 5 and was implicated
as a substrate receptor for an E3 ubiquitin ligase
complex. These tend to be adapter proteins that recognize
proteins that need to be degraded in the proteasome and
had been shown to proteolyze three different
targets here and is ubiquitously expressed.
And so then the question,
as we're thinking about this, why
would a ubiquitin ligase adapter constitute a specific vulnerability in
something that has a disrupted chromatin regulation? And that was surprising.
And began to think,
wonder, but going back to those papers that I quickly showed you, here's a rhabdoid
tumor cell line that's SMARCB1 deficient, and this is a glycerol gradient
showing the SWI/SNF complex. And if we turn SMARCB1 back
on, you see not only does SMARCB1 come on, but the abundance
of all of the other SWI/SNF subunits goes up.
We didn't know it at the time, but this was this third family of SWI/SNF complex
that didn't need SMARCB1. And so what we said is that SMARCB1
loss destabilizes the complex and causes it to fall apart.
But now with this new finding,
is it falling apart or might it actually be
degraded? And so it developed the hypothesis that in the absence of
SMARCB1, DCAF5 is degrading the components of the
misassembled SWI/SNF complex.
And the corollary to that hypothesis was, well, maybe in the absence of
DCAF5, if we knock it down or knock it out, these
residual subunits will accumulate.
They're missing a key subunit that docks on the nucleosome, so they're going to be
toxic, and they're going to get in the way of transcription, and that's going to
kill the cells.
And so went forward then with asking, what is the effect of
DCAF5 knockdown on SWI/SNF subunit abundance?
And this was one of the few times in my life when I was really
starting from scratch with a hypothesis that actually turned out to be correct.
And so as we look at mass spec analysis of the proteins that go up
upon DCAF5 knockdown, there were 18 proteins in the
predetermined window, nine of which were SWI/SNF subunits.
And so the people that do TMT profiling for a living, this was my first time
collaborating with them, said they've never seen a result like this.
And this was jumped off the page. Sandy went on to
try and make sure that that was right and so did what was called
DiGly tagging to look at which proteins
are actually getting ubiquitinated by
DCAF5 and found that three different SWI/SNF subunits
at multiple different sites are
dependent upon DCAF5 for ubiquitination.
Okay, so this thing is really now, this DCAF5 is indeed degrading
SWI/SNF subunits. What happens when you get rid of
DCAF5? And so we asked about where
it binds in the genome. And so when we turned SMARCB1 back on, we said that's going
to be the set of where SWI/SNF should normally be.
And then what we did was knock down DCAF5 and ask where the rest of the
SWI/SNF subunits went, and they went exactly where they were normally supposed to.
So the absence of SMARCB1 was not impairing the correct targeting of the
protein.
And so it was going back to where it was.
And so what is the effect now of these residual complexes upon
DCAF5 knockout? And remember, my corollary was that in the absence
of DCAF5, these things are going to accumulate, they're going to be toxic, and
they're going to shut down transcription.
And then Sandy, the grad student, formerly the research technician, now the
grad student, says, "Well, wait a minute.
Maybe the complex actually works
and you're rescuing its activity." And so I patiently
explained to Sandy, remember nucleosome here, the docking site here, we're missing
that. That's really not likely to happen.
So we made a bet,
and Sandy won.And so what
happens is when we knock out DCAF5, we see the SwitchNif
complex accumulating,
we're picking up. Now, it's not as strong as if you turn SMARCB1
back on. So if you rescue SMARCB1, you get a bigger peak, but you get a
substantial increase in peak just by knocking out DCAF5.
And then if we look at what happens to the genes that are being bound, they
don't go down as I had hypothesized, they go up.
So transcription is indeed being rescued.
And depending upon the assay we used, between 30% and
70% of wild-type activity now comes back.
What are the genes that are upregulated?
I won't go through it a lot, but they're basically the same genes as if you
normally turn on SMARCB1, and they are the genes
that are involved in normal development. And so this was a kidney model.
Kidney development goes up.
What happens when we go in vivo? So we did now a degrader tag
on DCAF5, put it in, did two cycles of degrading, and
I'd never really seen anything like that.
It completely wiped out the tumors, and they never came back.
We waited 100 days, and the tumors did not come back.
So DCAF5 is essential for cancer cells.
I didn't take time to show you this, but we made germline knockouts of the
mice, and they're viable.
So now we have a cancer target that wipes out a tumor so that it won't
come back, and yet the knockout mice are viable.
They're born at Mendelian ratio. They turn out to be slightly smaller than
the wild-type mice, and there's a small amount of neonatal lethality.
But if we think about the drugs that we use in the clinic now to treat cancer,
they're all pretty much targeting essential genes, things like
microtubules and others. Here we get something that has a very
mild phenotype.
Is this actually targetable? So it turns out it is in a family of
genes that have been proven to be targetable.
In working with Eric Fisher's lab at Dana-Farber and Nathaniel
Gray's lab at Stanford, we now have an initial binder of
DCAF5, and we have a big project going on to go after
that.
So I'll just go to the second to last bullet here that rather than
causing a second toxicity with this synthetic
lethality,
targeting DCAF5 rescues the normal function and is
essentially turning a cancer cell back to normal.
They differentiate. And interesting, might this be true
for other tumor suppressors?
Now, I want to tell you now another story that was unpublished as I put this talk
together but just came out last week led by Hayden
Malone, who also joined the lab as one of those
research technician positions.
While Hayden's here, I have to just brag about her a little bit.
She grew up in rural Mississippi, went to high school, decided there wasn't much
going on there, so decided to graduate high school in three years.
Goes to the University of Mississippi into the honors college,
gets the science bug,
does well, and as I'm looking for research technicians, her PI raves to
me about how talented she is. I recruit her into the lab for a two-year
position. She also picks the St. Jude Graduate School of Biomedical
Sciences and decides to come back to the lab.
So we're looking at what else is in these dependencies.
And Hayden gets intrigued by this dependency here that we
call FIP.
And so what she finds is, here's the rest of the cell lines in
DepMap, the now over 1,000 other cell lines.
Here's rhabdoid tumors that are SMARCB1 deficient.
And here's a version of ovarian cancer called small cell carcinoma of the
ovary that's got mutations in the SMARCA4 subunit of
SwitchNif.
And so FIP, it has chromatin binding domains,
bromodomains, Tudor domains, and it's overexpressed in several cancer
types, and so some biotech companies had begun to develop
binders.
While this had been implicated in DNA replication, what Hayden found
was that FIP actually localizes to active promoters,
H3K4 trimethyl, K27 acetyl, K14 acetyl,
mostly absence of the polycomb silencing mark.
And when she knocked down FIP in three different rhabdoid tumor cell lines, what
she sees is that these chromatin marks of activation go
down,
implicating FIP in transcriptional activation.
She then went on to look at, it had been shown to interact with an E3
ligase complex. And when she knocks down FIP in the
chromatin fraction, the members of that E3 complex no
longer bind to DNA. This was a bit surprising because
this complex can interact with multiple different E3 adapter
proteins, and yet getting rid of FIP is enough to get it to go away,
shown here with an siRNA knockdown of FIP,
what happens to the DDB1 subunit.
And so now again, we're really getting deep into transcriptional regulation is
what's going on here and becoming vulnerabilities.
So Hayden asked, "What is this thing ubiquitinating?" And what she pulls
out is all of these subunits of the Nurd repressor
complex. She went on to show in vitro that when she
puts FIP in in vitro, it will ubiquitinate the
subunits of this complex, CHD4 most strongly, but also
other subunits of the Nurd complex.
When she took a look at what
happens when you knock down FIP, what she finds is the Nurd complex
now increases its binding because it's no longer
getting degraded
and that this increase happens only specifically where FIP is bound.
And if you look at Nurd bound sites where there's no FIP, no change.
And so reading this out, FIP is normally here.
It's recruiting the CRL4 subunit here.
When you knock down FIP, the E3 complex is no longer recruited.
Nurd, one of the things it does is a histone deacetylase.
And so when you now see increased levels of CHD4,
you're now seeing decreased levels of H4
acetylation.Why is this coming up
specifically in SwitchNIF mutant cancers?
And so when she looked at a mutation here that
inactivates both subunits, ATPase subunits of SwitchNIF, it
creates a strong dependency compared to just losing one or the other.
Because of our earlier finding of publishing synthetic lethality between the two
subunits, ATPase subunits, companies had developed degraders.
And so here we degrade the ATPase subunits
or overexpress FIP now in 293T cells.
So overexpress, this is the abundance of NRD subunits.
Overexpressing FIP does nothing. Degrading SwitchNIF does nothing.
But when you degrade SwitchNIF and then overexpress FIP,
now you really reveal the ability of FIP that is active in
degrading NRD.
Does this happen? Is it dependent in vivo? So we go in vivo.
Now we see this is what happens with FIP intact.
When we knock out FIP,
we significantly prolong. We don't get the same DCAF5
effect, but that is because this was a pooled assay, and so
what's coming out the other end are cells that have now regained
expression of FIP. So when we're growing cells in
culture, we don't
overcome that
dependence. And so normally, SwitchNIF is antagonizing the NRD
complex at enhancers and promoters.
When SMARCB1 is lost,
you lose enhancers or decommissioned, and NRD complex removes
predominantly to promoters, where it is antagonized by FIP.
So whilst loss of SwitchNIF would normally lead to a shutdown of
transcription, this is rescued by
FIP's presence. And so when you target FIP, you now get the
transcriptional collapse that would result.
So I've talked about... I just mentioned that FIP, but we get
interested then in therapeutic targeting of FIP.
And now as we go from the graduate school all the way through postdoc
into current times, what we're really seeing is cancer
very strongly being promoted by disruption of fundamental
transcriptional control, disruption of lineage-specific
transcription programs, and the therapeutic
vulnerabilities that result have, in every case, been
mechanistically tied to the SwitchNIF complex.
And so facilitating career development can
really pay off in terms of people going on to doing
impactful science.
Hayden, in fact, is now going on to doing a postdoc with Gerry
Crabtree and Nathaniel Gray, working on proximity-induced
chemical modifications to therapeutically target cancer, one of the
hottest areas. And so now this model, as
I went to St. Jude, and people were no longer being recruited away, and I could
hire career technicians, but I've loved this model, and so I
continue to do this.
And look what's happened. Folks have gone on to the Harvard program, MIT,
Penn MD-PhD, Penn PhD, Tufts, incredible,
on and on. And so this has been one of the most incredible joys that I have
had is seeing people get the bug and go
on, and so we really designed these positions so that
they position people ideally for grad school and med
school. So investing in career development can launch
careers.
Functional genomics reveals mechanism.
That I think I've been talking about, but the EZH2 vulnerability,
SMARCA2, SMARCA4 paralog dependence, ARID1A, ARID1B I didn't
tell you about. We discovered the third subunit of the SwitchNIF complex,
PHF6 work by Priya, who's also
here. NSD1 antagonizes the SwitchNIF complex.
DCAF5 is involved in stability of the complex.
FIP, I just told you about, and genes X, Y, and Z are coming
along. In every single case as we do these screens, it's
illuminated the mechanism of how transcription actually works.
Been very powerful. Has it helped us with respect
to therapy? The answer has been, at least
early on, a resounding yes. So here's all the papers that are
related that have implicated therapeutic targets.
And so one FDA approval for tazemetostat, our
very first look, which is an EZH2 inhibitor in SMARCB1
or INI1-deficient cancers.
But here's a summary that Hayden put together
a little over a year and a half ago that we published looking now at all
the ability to target. And these are the ones that came out of
synthetic lethal screening, and these are the clinical trial numbers that are
going on over here. And so the rapidity with which these
things have moved from vulnerability screening into clinical
trials has been just incredible and very exciting, and we can now
add FIP to that list to look at.
I do want to take just two more minutes
to thank. Moving to St. Jude and becoming cancer center director really was an
opportunity to scale up then.
As Dr. Bono mentioned, COVID-19 strikes, and I began thinking, well, how do we
continue to educate everyone and engage now that scientists are being sent
home?
And so I had some ideas. Can we engage people virtually?
And so I decided to, being the scientist, to do an experiment with a
weekly one-hour lecture versus an annual virtual conference,
two-day conference. And so we launched both of them.
And she mentioned some of this. We launched it in 2020.
I thought once the pandemic ended, the thirst would go away.
We've done 172 lectures, 11,000 attendees,
thousands of trainees,
128 countries and territories represented globally,
391 attendees per lecture this year.
This has just been phenomenal. As I look about...
So these areThe top scientists in the field from any
institution that are talking, and now look at all of these countries,
people that never would've had a chance to see a Nobel laureate give a lecture,
to see the top science, can now engage, and lots of people at top
centers in the US. And the Bringing Chemistry to Medicine
symposium has similarly done well, and so it ended up
being a bit of a both/and, that they both work and enable
people to engage, but in different ways.
And so really thinking about that.
Lastly, we've launched a high school immersion program.
For the first summer of 16 students, we got 380
applications, and so we've scaled up.
We now have 50 high school students this summer.
As mentioned, I'm the PI of a K12 program, thinking about how do we
facilitate clinical research training in pediatric cancer.
And then Damon Runyon called us when the Sohn Foundation had pulled out.
We need pediatric-focused funding, and so we have picked that up, and that has
been phenomenal.
Success in life has nothing to do with what you gain or accomplish for yourself,
it's what you do for others. And my last takeaway point,
I was going to say for mentors, but I think it's for everybody.
Giving feedback is a gift.
It helps people learn and grow. It's also a
responsibility. And when you do it, and you engage people, and you're
truly thinking about how it will help them, it's a
joy to do, because then that's the way that people learn.
It's how I learned when people gave me critical feedback in my
career. And if I leave people with one point, this would be the
point. So thank you to everyone who was involved.
I highlighted the folks along the way who've done the work.
These are the collaborations we've had going on, Nathaniel Gray's
lab, Eric Fisher's lab, the Broad Institute, and a number of people at St.
Jude, and funding, and I'm happy to take questions.
Thank you. We've kind of run out of our time, but we probably can do a couple of
quick questions. If anybody has one, please go to the mic and
introduce yourself.
If not, I have a final question for you.
Great. Sorry, I went longer than I thought I would getting it all in.
That's no,
no worries.
We're in challenging times right now.
Science is facing a lot of challenges, and I wonder
what advice you're giving mentees about that right
now.
Yeah, it's a good question. I think about times come and go,
and it's really hard to know. I think about this on the medical side.
I just used as an example, nursing.
There are some years where people have huge recruitment things going on and signing
bonuses for nurses, and then there's some years that it's super hard to
find a job as a nurse.
So coming back to graduate training, my own son is a third-year PhD student
in cancer biology at WashU, so I think deeply about this.
What I say is follow what you love. Do what you love.
It's too hard to predict the future as to what's going to be there, what's not.
We just heard from Tony Letai. I had the privilege of hearing from him four
different times. NCI is going to be releasing much more money this
year. Things are looking upright.
I think keep going if you're in it. Engage career development, talk to
your mentors.
But I would not flee the field. I'm certainly not telling my son to flee the field.
Thank you, and congratulations again, Dr. Roberts.
Thank you.